what is up there reject nation so this
got sent our way this just sounded like
a delightful youtube video spider-man no
way home trailer but with a 38 84 budget
this comes from the youtube channel
albert lung so guys make sure to
subscribe to him especially when i'm
enjoying this video this sounds like
vintage youtube to me
let's check it out
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one
where my life is felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
[Laughter]
not a studio watch that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
in every
universe
[Music]
hello peter
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name the golf clubs
we need to send it back
so
scooby doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
[Music]
flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all died
their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too
don't
that's great
they're a danger to our universe
you have to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
yeah
the shield
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th will not be in movie
theaters tickets on sale eventually
spider someday
that had to have cost more than 38
dollars that suit alone costs 38 dollars
well you know that's where the 84 cents
comes in the rest of everything cost 84
cents that was super funny it's easy to
look at this and go spider-man no way
home with a 38 budget and be like ash is
some little goofy video that people put
together believe me
we know that that takes
a lot of time and energy and especially
the editing i imagine the editing took a
quite a while to put together on that
because you are really trying to sync it
up perfectly with each clip and even
like the delivery of the dialogue i'd be
very curious to know if while they were
doing it if they had the actual audio
playing in the background so they can
make sure their lips were perfectly
matching with it yeah but to get all
these shots even as much as supposed to
look like janky and lo-fi and gorilla
film making style that takes a lot of
coordination and a lot of time to to
assemble like you're looking at all
different times of day where they were
having to get these shots and i'm sure
there were even some shots i can imagine
even like the tennis ball shot whether
we're catching the goblin ball i bet
that even took some time to get together
you got it this takes a lot of
preparation so don't be misled by the
title and the gimmick of the overall
presentation some real work went into
that oh yeah absolutely and it's fun to
see where your problem solving had to go
because you look throughout this and
certain things look a little more
faithfully recreated than other things
yeah i love that for the spell you
actually have just a guy with a wad of
rope lights just kind of crouching down
underneath the table you know to kind of
create that effect of the the rings
coming together but then you know you
have like a location with this actual
like web bungee thing that you guys make
great use out of in order to orchestrate
you know like a spider web in a more
practical setting and like the only shot
that seemed like you had to do i mean
i'm sure there were visual effects of
some oh yeah you guys definitely know
adobe yeah yeah yeah yeah but uh you
know it's like you have that one shot of
him actually swinging past the screen
from the trailer with your face
photoshopped in but the rest of it yeah
is is so charmingly diy and i imagine
too not only does it take a long time to
get the shot right and to make sure
every prop is where it needs to be it's
also really hard to just map out like
what needs to be in a location shot what
we can do at i assume at home and what
should be all the same actors versus
what do we need like multiple people on
screen to do is really charmingly uh you
know informative in a way i feel like
you could deconstruct this or reverse
engineer this video and kind of look
everywhere and see just yeah like what
the approach to problem solving was and
that's kind of the most charming aspect
i love the tennis ball yeah is the
stand-in for the green goblin pumpkin
monk it's like there's an orange prop in
the movie but even here just seeing it
roll down the street you're like oh yeah
it's his colors so it's even more
indicative in this moment the split
second moment of it a big part of what
makes moments like this especially so
charming is that if you see like the
other crew in the shot or someone like
waving down some smoke or moving the
camera or the light around it just works
the great charm the thing that can be
really time consuming on especially on a
project like this that has so many shots
like there's a lot of shots you got to
do i can imagine that the
the thing that you would probably get
pretty particular about is making sure
that the frame matched with it like when
you're recreating a shot which you care
about most of the time i imagine is like
as long as the frame is matching like
what's in the frame of that trailer shot
let's try to get that shot even if we
can't do the visual effects and stuff
you know yeah as long as it gets your
mind to snap directly to the shot that
we're referencing mission accomplished
that was hysterical
i am very much impressed with that i i
quite enjoyed that a lot oh yeah and
it's just the right blend you know
because some of the shots it's like
impressive well done and some of the
shots are like it's just you holding a
miniature plane in front of the camera
and it's yeah it's it's wonderful it
made me want to go out and make
something like this all right guys well
subscribe to albert long because this
channel absolutely deserves it subscribe
to us best bet we got spider-man no way
home content coming the week last but
not least let's do a pic
gene jeter the king of diy you should
why it would like you make so many riffs
on well-established genres of youtube
video you got to make a trailer
recreation gene you know so many models
and actors heck you yourself could get
in front of the camera that would be
something to see you could be miles
morales in your own uh you know
recreation of the spider-man across the
spider-verse part one trailer think of
the possibilities gene plus you're a
photographer you've already got a leg up
in terms of equipment you have on hand
that you could use both to capture but
also to stand in look at this video half
of doc ock's arms were just all monopods
so gene get on top of that man there's
so many great trailers dropping all year
long you should be not having any
shortage of inspiration man
is this the video today where you just
keep slapping your pants
you